اسعد الله اوقاتكم بكل خير واهلا بكم الى
نشره الخامسه من العربيه التي نستهلها
باببرز العناوين
رئيس فاقنر يقر بان الوضع في بخمه صعب
للغايه والمعركه على المدينه تستنزف
الطرفين الروسي والاوكراني
وكاله الطاقه الذريه تدعو لضمان عدم وجود
مخاطر نوويه وراء صفقه الغواصات
الاستراليه يحذر من مواجهه لسنوات في اسيا
الاسهم الماليه العالميه تفقد
465 مليار دولار خلال ثلاثه ايام عقبا
انهيار بنك سيليكون فالي
وطالب ان تغلق المكتبه الوحيده التي تسمح
بدخول النساء في كابول والنساء تتوعدن
بفتح مكتبات سريه
اهلا بكم الى نشره الخامسه من العربيه
تتواصل المعارك على الجبهات الاوكرانيه في
وقت ما تزال فيه معركه بخموت غير محسومه
تماما وتتحول الى معركه استنزاف للطرفين
الاوكراني والروسي رئيس فاجنر يفجن
بريكوجين الذي تقاتل قواته على الخطوط
الاماميه مع الروس قال ان عناصره كلما
اقتربوا من وسط مدينه باخموت ازدادت
المعارك قسوه مع استخدام سلاح المدفعيه
واوضح ان قواته تواجه مقاومه شرسه وان
الوضع في باخمت صعب للغايه مضيفا بان
الاوكرانيين يدفعون باحتياطات لا نهايه
لها في المعركه
هذا ويسعى الروس بكل ما بوسعهم للسيطره
على بخمه الواقعه في الدومباس شرق
اوكرانيا وتقول موسكو ان السيطره على بخ
مت ستحدث ثغره في الدفاعات الاوكرانيه
وبالتالي ستؤدي الى السيطره الكامله على
منطقه الصناعيه وهي هدف كبير في هذه الحرب
فاذا سقطت باخموت هناك ثلاث طرق صعبه فقط
يمكن للروس من خلالها الوصول الى كرمترسك
الجائزه الاستراتيجيه لهم في الدومباس
الخبراء يعتقدون انه لا توجد طريق لقوه
روسيه منهكه في باخموت تعاني اشكالا
داخليا بين الجيش النظامي ومجموعه
وحتى لو تمكنت فاجنر من اختراق فقد اشترت
اوكرانيا وقتا كافيا لجعل الطريق الى
كرامه غير سالك امام الروس وفق المخابرات
العسكريه الاوكرانيه
وفي شان متصل صوت البرلمان الروسي لصالح
قانون يفرض رقابه واسعه على منتقدي القوات
المسلحه والمتطوعين المشاركين في العمليات
العسكريه في اوكرانيا بما في ذلك مجموعه
وبموجب القوانين الروسيه الحاليه يمكن ان
تصل عقوبه من يدان بتهمه تشويه سمعه الجيش
والمشاركين في العمليات باوكرانيا الى
السجن لسبع سنوات في حين قد تصل عقوبه نشر
معلومات كاذبه عمدا عن الجيش الى السجن
لمده 15 عاما
من موسكو معي لمزيد من المتابعه المحلل
العسكري الروسي
اهلا وسهلا بك لماذا حتى الساعه تبدو
باخمت عصيه على القوات الروسيه وعلى
مجموعات فاجنير ولماذا تبدو القوات
الروسيه وكانها عالقه في هذا المستنقع
السلام عليكم تحيه طيبه من موسكو فعلا
معركه ضخمه
تستغرق
فتره طويله جدا يعني اعتبارا من اب العمل
الماضي
فلحد الان
تمكنت القوات الاماميه
لترف الروسي
لاسيما منتسبين مجموعه فاقده يعني اشاركة
العسكريه الخاصه تمكنت من الاستيلاء على
60% فقط بمدينه محمود
ما هو السبب لتاخير هذه حتى الى هناك تقدم
يوميا
بمسافه معينه
هناك عده اسباب اولا
الاهميه لهذه المعركه من الناحيه
السياسيه والناحيه الاعلاميه تتفوق على
اهميتها العسكريه بمعنى انه كيف تستخدم
بخموت كرمز الصمود والمقاومه ويقول
الرئيسكي ان
من المستبعد ان تنسحب القوات الاوكرانيه
من تلك المدينه طيب موسكو من موسكو من
دورها تقول انه
موضوع الاستيلاء على مدينه بالكامل هو
مجرد موضوع الزمن قد تستغرق الابعاريه بعد
اسبوعين او ثلاثه او شهر او حتى شهرين
ولكن في نهايه الامل نحن
نتحرك
حتى في
هذه المعركه اطول من معركه ماريوبل ومن
معركه ازوف ستال طيب برغم السيطره الجويه
الروسيه وقوه النار الروسيه حتى الساعه ما
زال الاوكرانيون القوات الاوكرانيه يعني
تنجح في صد كل هذه الهجمات السؤال البعض
يقول انه لا يعني السبب الاساسي هو عدم
التنسيق بين فاجنر والقوات الروسيه او
الخلافات ان صح التعبير بين القوات
الروسيه النظاميه ومجموعات فاجنبي هي التي
تحول دون السيطره الروسيه الكامله على
المدينه ما رايك
هناك اسباب وليس سبب واحد الاسباب هذه من
ناحيه المعركه التي تجري في بخموت هي
معركه الشوارع قتال الشوارع هذا اصعب ما
يمكن من العمليات القتاليه والان تابع
العمليات في بخمت تحول الى تابع بعد اسع
من قتال الشوارع وهو قتال الانفاق لان بعد
استيلاء جماعه على ستين بالميه من مدينه
بخموت انسحبت بعض القوات الاوكرانيه فيها
واخذت المواقع الدفاعيه في في
الفاكهه هذه تمتد عشرات من كيلومترات
وبعنق 350 وحتى 400 متر تحت سطر الارض
يعني
هذا اصعب واتعب بكثير من قتال الشوارع وهو
منقسم العمليات القتاليه
نعم بالفعل هناك خلافات معينه بين رئاسه
جماعه
وقياده الجيش النظامي ولكن
بعد ما ظهرت هذه
التساؤلات هل بالفعل ستؤثر على خوض
المعركه وهل هناك خلافات جذريه فرد سحب
الشركه
قولا ان جماعه بغداد تبقى وستبقى
جزءا من
الاليه العسكريه الروسيه سوف تواصل انا
سؤال بيساله كمان المشاهدين يعني طيب هذه
المعركه طويله جدا وباخمت محاصره بشكل
كبير من اين تتلقى القوات الاوكرانيه
الامدادات طالما هنالك سيطره جويه روسيه
والمدينه محاصره لا نريد ان اقول بالكامل
ولكن بشكل شبه كامل
هذا هو الجواب المدينه محاسبه بشكل غير
كامل بمعنى هناك طريق واحد ولو الطريق هذا
تحت جيران المدفعيه الروسيه ولكن الطريق
هذه
يتم استخدامه من قبل الطرف الاخرى دي حتى
الان للامدادات والنقل واخلال الجرحى
والقتل والى اخره اذا نعم مدينه هي محاصره
ولكن ليس هناك احكام السد مثل ما يقال
يعني محاسنه ليس بشكل محكم ومضمون
ومعلن الموضوع ان
المعركه بالفعل صعب جدا
وداميه يعني
وكل من الطرفين يتعرض للخسائر الفاضحه في
الارواح والمعدات
بالتاكيد
ضخمه سوف تسقط قريبا ولكن عندما يقال ان
بعد الاستيلاء على مدينه ضخمه سوف
يقوم الجيش الروسي بتقدم بوتيره عاليه
وهناك اراضي مفتوحه نوعها لا اشارك هذه
وجهه النظر لان وراء هناك خط دفاعي اخر من
اخره وتلك المدن محسنه بعد احسن
ساكتفي بهذا القدر من موسكو وسرقه شاشكوف
المحلل العسكري الروسي شكرا جزيلا لك على
هذه المشاركه
وزير الخارجيه الروسيه الولايات المتحده
واستراليا وبريطانيا بتدبير مواجهه تستمر
لسنوات في اسيا عبر اطلاقها تحالف اكوس
بشان الغواصات النوويه
التحتيه لحلف شمال الاطلسي في اسيا و
يراهن بجديه على مواجهه تستمر لسنوات
طويله الولايات المتحده تبذل مساعي لاخضاع
دول اسيا لارادتها هذا يجب ان يتوقف
وفي المقابل اعلنت الولايات المتحده
واستراليا وبريطانيا رسميا عن اتفاق اوكوس
وبموجبه تتسلم استراليا غواصات تعمل
بالطاقه النوويه
هذه الخطوه تاريخيه بالنسبه لاستراليا
التي قال رئيس وزرائها انها الاكبر في
الاستثمار العسكري في تاريخ البلاد
بارغانم من واشنطن والتفاصيل
احتفل الرئيس الامريكي جو بايدن مع رئيسي
وزراء بريطانيا واستراليا باتفاق اوكوس
على منصه في سانيجو وتظهر في الخلفيه
غواصه من نوع فرجينيا ستتسلى مثيلاتها
استراليا بنهايه العقد
اريد ان اكون واضحا منذ البدايه فلا يكون
هناك اللغط او سوء فهم فهذه النقطه مفصليه
الغواصات تسير بالقوه النوويه وليست مسلحه
نوويا مسيره وليست مسلحه نوويا
شدد الرئيس الامريكي كثيرا على هذه الميزه
في محاوله للتاكيد ان الولايات المتحده لا
تسعى مع استراليا الى تهديد الدول في
المحيط الهادئ خصوصا الصين
اتفاق اوكسو الذي نؤكده هنا في ساندييجو
يمثل اكبر استثمار في امكانيه استراليا
العسكريه في تاريخ بلادنا
ويشمل الاتفاق الذي اعلن عنه بدايه
التعاون بين البحريه الامريكيه
والاستراليه في مجال الغواصات المسيره على
القوات النوويه ثم تسليم استراليا ثلاث
غواصات امريكيه على ان تتعاون بريطانيا
والولايات المتحده في بناء غواصات بصناعه
استراليه
تزيد الغواصات والسفن المسيره بالطاقه
النوويه من مسافه الابحار وهذا يعني
الابتعاد عن شواطئ استراليا والاقتراب من
شواطئ الصين ومن الخطوط البحريه الصينيه
الى الشرق الاوسط من حيث يستوردون الطاقه
جاء اتفاق اوكوس على حساب فرنسا اولا لانه
استراليا تخلت عن شراء الغواصات الفرنسيه
كما يبدو الاتفاق تهيئه لمواجهه المحاولات
الصينيه للتوسع في المحيط الهادئ رئيس
وزراء بريطانيا لم يتردد في الحديث عن
المخاطر
عند في الاشهر الثمانيه عشر الماضيه
تصاعدت التحديات التي واجهناها من اجتياح
روسيا لاوكرانيا الى التصرفات الصينيه
والاضطرابات التي تسببت بها ايران وكوريا
الشماليه وكلها تهدد العالم بالمخاطر
والاضطرابات والانقسام يبدو هذا الاتفاق
على انه تاهيل واضح للقوه العسكريه
الاستراليه بدعمًا من الولايات المتحده
وبريطانيا وايا كانت التبريرات فهذا
التاهيل العسكري لاستراليا يبدو موجها ضد
الصين العربيه
نشط الخامسه مستمره فيها بعض الفاصل
جلسه استجواب غدا لحاكم المصرف المركزي في
قضايا اختلاس اموال عامه والعمله
اللبنانيه تنهار امام الدولار بواقع مئه
الف ليره للدولار الواحد
اهلا بكم من جديد استقبل رئيس حكومه اقليم
كردستان العراق مسرور بارزاني رئيس
الوزراء العراقي محمد شياع السوداني في
العاصمه اربيل وبحسب مصادر العربيه سيلتقي
السوداني مع كبار المسؤولين في الاقليم
ومن المقرر ان يزور بعد ذلك محافظه
السليمانيه رئيس الوزراء العراقي محمد
شياع السوداني كان قد اعلن التوصل الى
اتفاق شامل بشان القضايا العالقه بين
الحكومه الاتحاديه في بغداد وحكومه اربيل
هذا واعلنت وزاره المال والاقتصاد في
حكومه اقليم كردستان تسلمها
273 مليون دولار في اطار الاتفاق مع
الحكومه الاتحاديه لتمويل رواتب موظفي
الاقليم
من اربيل لمزيد من المتابع انضم الي من
هناك مراسل العربيه احمد الحمداني احمد ما
الذي رشح عن كل لقاءات السيد محمد شياع
السوداني مع المسؤولين في كردستان العراق
وهل فعلا هنالك اتفاق شامل على كل القضايا
العالقه ام لا يعني هذا كلام عام ما زالت
هنالك خلافات في كثير من التفاصيل
اهلا طالب طبعا في البدايه اللقاء كان مع
رئيس الحكومه مصروف بارزاني الذي استقبله
في مطار اربيل الدولي والان سيكون لديه
رئيس وزراء السوداني سيكون لديه اجتماع مع
نيجران بارزاني رئيس اقليم كردستان ومن
بعدها سيكون مع الزعيم الكردي مسعود
بارزاني لم يترشح عن الاجتماعات لكن في
مجمل في مجمل في في مجمل العام الاجتماعات
تصب في الاتفاق الذي وصف من بعض انه اتفاق
تاريخي ما بين اربيل وبغداد وان العقبات
قد ازيلت وان الاليه اليه البرنامج واليه
قد طبقت بامس باقرار الموازنه العراقيه
التي تضمنت مرتبات اقليم كردستان بالاضافه
الى ان النفط والغاز العقده الكبيره لدى
ما بين بغداد واربيل قد حلت بانشاء حساب
بنكي ما اعتقد او صندوق يودع به واردات
نفط اقليم كردستان والغاز يشرف على هذا
الصندوق
شخصيا محمشاه السوداني رئيس الوزراء
العراقي
وطبعا بالاضافه الى ان صحيح انها لم تحسم
من قبل البرلمان لم يصوت الا ان في الجو
العام ان الكتل السياسيه او الفرقاء
السياسيين هم من دفعوا بهذا الاتفاق وهذه
الاليه كون انهم استاندوا طالب على قانون
او او اتفاقيه اداره الدوله العراقيه التي
بموجبها شكلت حكومه السودان بالتالي امام
السوداني الكثير من اللقاءات هنا في اقليم
كردستان اربيل ومن ثم سليمان احمد ظلت
العلاقه شائكه بين بغداد واربيل وفيها
الكثير من مشاعر التوجس طيب اذا سلمنا جدل
ان هنالك اتفاق على موضوع عائدات النفط
بالنسبه الى الموازنه هل هنالك اتفاق شامل
وكامل بين الطرفين ام لا يعني في ايضا
كثير من الثغرات ربما تفجر الاتفاق برمته
سؤال مهم طالب طبعا الموازنه موازنات
العراق
وخلافه مع بغداد هي طبعا لب الخلاف في هذه
النقطه او جوهرها هو ايرادات النفط والغاز
والجمارق العراقيه الموجوده في اقليم
كردستان ما ان اتفق الطرفين ماء اتفقوا
على ان يكون هناك صندوق لوضع الايرادات
والنفط والغاز وكذلك ربما ايضا المعابر
الحدوديه حتى يكون هناك قد سهل اقد اقد
حلت المشكله موافقه تقليم كردستان وبغداد
على هذه البنت كان كان هو عقده العقده
التي كانت امامهم طبعا يكون هناك قد حلت
المشكله جذريا ان طبقت بهذا بهذا الاتجاه
سيكون ايرادات ستكون صادرات النفط والغاز
فيه اقليم كردستان عن نفسها تستمر كما هي
في عقودها مع الشركات النفط لكن الايرادات
تعود الى صندوق يشرف عليه تشرف عليه بغداد
ولكن ملفت الانتباه او نعم في هذه القضيه
ان اربيل حتى وين سلمت النفط والغاز
وايراداتها وهل هذه لكن هي تبقى تبقى تطلب
او تبقى بغداد مدينه لاربيل بمليارات
الدولارات كون ان منذ عام 2014 عندما كان
المالكي هو رئيس الوزراء قطع الموازنات عن
اربيل وبالتالي لا يكفي انتاج النفط
والغاز ما يسده بالتالي فانها تطلب او او
ان بغداد مدينه لاربيل لمبارك ساكتفي بهذا
القدر من اربيل مراسل العربي احمد
الحمداني شكرا جزيلا لك على كل هذه
المتابعه
فقدت الاسهم الماليه العالميه
465 مليار دولار من قيمتها السوقيه خلال
ثلاثه ايام مع خفض المستثمرين لانكشافهم
على المصارف عقبا انهيار بنك سيليكون فالي
وكانت البنوك الامريكيه هي الاكثر تضررا
بين الشركات المدرجه بمؤشر ام اس سي اي
المالي العالمي ويعد سهم بنك فيرست
ريبابليك اكبر الخاسرين حسب هذا المؤشر
اذا انخفض بنحو 74% خلال ثلاث جلسات
وفي جديد تطورات ازمه اس في بي اكد رئيسه
الاحتياطي الفيدرالي جيرومباول ان التعثر
المفاجئ لبنك سيليكون فالي يستدعي مراجعه
شامله وشفافه وسريعه
واضاف باول ان نائب رئيس مجلس اداره
الاحتياط الفيدرالي مايكل بار سيقود
الاشراف على هذه المراجعه وسيتم نشر
النتائج في الاول من مايو هذا وكان
الاحتياطي الفيدرالي وشركه التامين على
الودائع الفيدراليه قد اكد حمايه كامل
قيمه الودائع في مصرفي سيليكون فالي
وسجنتشر بانك وليس فقط ما قيمته 250 الف
دولار تجدر الاشاره الى ان البرنامج
الاخير للفدرالي لا يحمل المساهمين او
الدائنين للمصارف المتعثره كما اطلق
الاحتياطي الفيدرالي برنامج التمويل
البنكي لاجل وهو المعروف باسم بنك تيرم
بروجرام والذي سيقدم قروضا تصل الى عام
واحد لمؤسسات الايداع مدعومه بسندات
الخزانه الامريكيه والاوراق الماليه
المدعومه بالرهن العقاري
افادت مصادر قضائيه للعربيه بانه ستعقد
جلسه استجواب لحاكم مصرف لبنان رياض سلامي
امام القاضي شربل ابو سمره في قضايا
اختلاس اموال عامه صباح غد الاربعاء
واكد المصدر نفسه انه من المنتظر ان يحضر
سلامه شخصيا الجلسه لانه وكلاءه
القانونيين لم يقدموا دفوعا شكليه بحضورهم
نيابه عنه وان تحقيق معه سيكون بحضور قاض
فرنسي من ضمن وفد المحققين الاوروبيين
الموجود في لبنان
من جهه اخرى هبطت الليره اللبنانيه الى
مستوى مئه الف مقابل الدولار الواحد في
السوق الموازية وهو رقم جديد في مسار
المعاناه الطويل الذي تعيشه العمله
اللبنانيه منذ نهايه عام 2019
وسجل هذا المستوى القياسي في وقت استانفت
فيه المصارف اضرابا مفتوحا اليوم
وكان سعر الصرف الرسمي حدد عند مستوى خمسه
عشر الف ليره في مقابل الدولار في فبراير
الماضي بعد ان كان السعر الرسمي لليره
اللبنانيه يبلغ
1520 ليره للدولار وهو سعر بقي ثابتا
ومعتمدا لسنوات طويله
المشكله انه تتبعات ارتفاع الدولار هلا
البنزين الخبز يعني الله يساعدها العالم
يعني الله يساعدنا كمان من جنه هالعالم
زعماء
وعم يغنوا
ولا زعيم ولا نائب ولا حدا عم بفكر
بهالشعب المعطل كل يوم شكل
بلشنا بالاناجيت هون انا مسافر برا يعني
جيت لهون هلا صار ميه فما فيني ما حدا
يهتم بهالب فقير
عالم ما تمشي يا عمي شو هالبلد لوين
رايحين
ما بعرف
معي من بيروت لمزيد من المتابعه الصحفيه
المختصه في الشؤون الاقتصاديه سلبين عويس
اهلا وسهلا بك هل فعلا يمكن تاكيد جلسه
الاستجواب غدا وان الحاكم رياض سلامه
سيحضر هذه المره ام لا كالعاده كما جرت
العاده لا يحضر هذه الجلسات حتى جلسات
الاستجواب النيابيه لم يكن يحضرها
صحيح مساء الخير
صحيحه هلا حتى الان حتى الان المعلومات
تشير الى انه سيحضر وكما تفضلت وقلت
بمقدمه الخبر انه بسبب عدم تقديم الدفوع
الشكليه لذلك المحامون محاموه سلامي لن
يحضروا سيحضر هو شخصيا الجو في بيروت حسب
المعلومات انه بلغت الامور مستوى الضغط
الكبير سيما وانه هناك قضاه اوروبيين
سيشاركون ايضا لذلك المطلوب من سلامه
حضوره الشخصي هل هذا يقفل الملف او يفتح
على احتمالات اكبر واوسع حتى الان لا يمكن
الحديث عن هذا الموضوع لانه يخشى من
الجانب الامني لانه رياض سلامه مهدد امنيا
ولا يتحرك كثيرا او لا يعلن بالاحرى عن
تحركاته لذلك لا ندري اذا كان فعلا سيحضر
او انه قال ذلك يعني
يتراجع عن قراره في اللحظه الاخيره
لنسلم جدلا انه حضر هل يمكن توقع ان
القضاء اللبناني الان يعني سيشرب حليب
سباع كما يقال ويصدر مذكره توقيف وجاهيه
بحق الحاكم المركزي ام لا الغطاء السياسي
والفيتوهات والخطوط الحمراء ستفعل فعلها
مره اخرى
صحيح هو الخشيه الوحيده من حضوره الشخصي
هي عمليه التوقيف الفوري لانه اذا بتتذكر
عندما كانت القاضيه غاده عون تطالب
باحضاره للتحقيق وكان يعني تذهب قوه من
شعبه المعلومات او عفوا ليست شعبه
المعلومات من الدوله من الامن الدوله
لاحضاره نعم لاحضاره وكان يعني لا يجدونه
علما انه معروف المقر يعني مقر الاقامه
يعني ان كان او في منزلها او في المصرف
المركزي اليوم انا اعتقد انه لكي يقول انه
سيحضر هناك ضمانات بانه يكون حضوره من دون
ان يترافق ذلك مع صدور قرار بتوقيفه اليوم
مسار رياض سلامه اخذ سلك سلك سلك مساره
القانوني والقضائي ولم يعد هناك اي قدره
على التراجع سيما وانه بات هذا الملف مح
تحت المجهر الدولي وكانت المحاوله بفتح
التحقيق الداخلي في لبنان لمنع اخراج اي
معلومات عن المصارف عن قطاع المصرفي عن
السياسيين المعرضين الى الخارج لانه ايضا
المسار القضائي في الخارج ولاسيما في
اوروبا سيسلك طريقه حتى النهايه لذلك نعم
سبيل فقد لكي لا يفوتنا الوقت الحديث عن
العمله اللبنانيه الليره الان هو حديث
مواجع خصوصا لموظفي القطاع العام في لبنان
اليوم وصلوا يعني الدولار الواحد الى ما
يساوي 100 الف ليره لبنانيه في انهيار
مفجع هل يمكن الربط بين
انهيار الليره بهذا الشكل المتسارع
والاحتمالات توقيف حاكم المصرف المركزي
هذا واحد اثنين طيب هل الامور منفلته من
كل عقال يعني لا يوجد ضابط ربما يعني هذه
الليره مستمره في انهيار الى مستويات غير
مسبوقه
هذا هو الواقع في الحقيقه يعني العامل
الثاني هو الحقيقه
الكامله في الموضوع يعني اليوم الدولار
الامريكيه تعين الليره اللبنانيه تتعرض
للضغوط والدولار يرتفع حسب بعض الاخبار
ساعه صعودا او ساعه نزولا ولكن بطريقه
ظرفيه جدا يعني اي تاثر للدولار بحدث
سياسي او امني لا يستغرق اكثر من بضعه
ساعات ليعود الى مساره المسار الارتفاع
لذلك اليوم الدولار لم يعد مرتبط ابدا
ارتفاعه باي عوامل اقتصاديه هناك حركه طلب
قويه عليه ولكن ليس لحاجات السوق
اللبنانيه بقدر ما هي لعمليه تهريب والى
الخارج هناك حاجه في لدى عدد من الدول
العربيه سوريا مصر
لدولارات تسحب من السوق اللبناني وتصدر
الى الخارج مع الاسف
لذلك اليوم الدولار لم يعد له سقوف
ربما يرتبط بمكان ما باحد الاسباب بعمليه
استجواب رياض سلامه ولكن يمكنني ان اؤكد
لك ان هذه الضغوط تذهب اكثر في السياسه
لذلك يمكن ان نراه اكثر فاكثر يرتفع الى
ما فوق المئه الف ليره حسب تطورات الملف
غدا حسب يعني نرجو ان لا نصل الى اماكن
سلبيه جدا لانه بالنتيجه نحن نريد القضاء
ان يكون مستقلا ويتخذ قراراته بموجب
استقلاليته وليس بسبب ضغوط سياسيه يتعرض
لها من جهه اخرى الليره تفقد قيمتها وكما
سمعت في التقرير الناس تشكو ولكن لا احد
يحرك ساكنا يعني هناك فقط شكوى ولكن
الامور تسير على طبيعتها مع الاسف
والارتفاع يستمر الى ما لا نهايه للاسف من
بيروت الصحفيه المختصه في الشؤون
الاقتصاديه شكرا جزيلا لك على هذه
المشاركه
صدقت الهيئه العامه للكنيسه بالقراءه
الاولى على قانون التقويض المحكمه العليا
وسحب صلاحياتها والمعروف بقانون فقره
التغلب والذي يسمح للكنيسه بالالتفاف على
القرارات الصادره عن المحكمه العليا في
حال توفرت اغلبيه 61 نائبا وصوت الى جانب
القانون 61 نائبا بينما عرضه 52 من اعضاء
الكنيسه حيث اتى ذلك بعد المصادقه
بالقراءه الاولى على مشروع قانون اساس
الحكومه الذي يمنع عزل رئيس حكومه من
منصبه والاعلان عن تعذره عن القيام بمهامه
[تصفيق]
ينص مشروع قانون الالتفاف على المحكمه
العليا على انه يحق للمحكمه العليا الغاء
قانون شرعه الكنيست بمصادقه هيئه قضائيه
موسعه
بالاضافه الى تعديل للماده رقم ثمانيه من
قانون اساس كرامه الانسان وحريته والماده
رقم اربعه من قانون اساس حريه العمل
كما صادق الكنيست بالقراءه الاولى على
مشروع قانون الغاء قانون الانفصال فالضفه
الغربيه وقطاع غزه
يلغي مشروع القانون قرار الانفصال عن
المستوطنات التي تم تفكيكها عام 2005 بهدف
شرعنه بؤر استيطانيه عشوائيه شمال الضفه
الغربيه
على كل لمزيد من المتابعه معي هنا في
الاستوديو زياد حلبي مراسل العربيه في
القدس زياد اهلا وسهلا بك دائما مصطلح
قانون اصلاح قضائي كلمه اصلاح مطاطه
وحماله اوجه ودائما تحمل عناوين ايجابيه
ولكن ربما تكون في الحقيقه لا فقط لنفهم
المشاهدين لماذا هذا ما يسمى بقانون
الاصلاح القضائي خطير كما تراه المعارضه
الاسرائيليه
صحيح عمليا طالب ما ترمي اليه هو بالضبط
لب المشكل بمعنى الشكل لا يوحي بالمضمون
يقال من قبل الحكومه بانه اصلاح في القضاء
لكن وعلى فكره وهذا ما ربما يجب على
المشاهد ان يعيه غالبيه الاسرائيليين اكثر
من 60% في جميع استطلاعات الراي ترفض هذا
الموضوع وتعرضه بشده لان الشعور العام في
اسرائيل بان حكومه اليمين برئاسه بنيامين
نتنياهو تريد من خلال الاغلبيه البرلمانيه
ان تغير دراماتيكيا المعطيات في نظام
السياسي في اسرائيل العلاقه ما بين النظام
القضائي وسلطه التنفيذيه لصالح الاخيره
بمعنى تريد ان تسيطر على ماهيه القضاه على
تعيين القضاه ان تسيطر على اللجنه التي
تعين القضاه واكثر من ذلك ان تمنع المحكمه
العليا عمليا من التدخل لصالح الفرد او
المجموعه في اسرائيل في حال قررت الحكومه
في الكنيست مررت اي مشروع اساس تمنع
المحكمه العليا من معالجه هذا الامر بهذا
المعنى خرج في اسرائيل هذه طبعا ليست
مشكله يسار ويمين ابدا في اسرائيل وربما
النظره بعمق الى الموضوع توحي بان النخب
الاساسيه في اسرائيل ممثله برجال الاعمال
بكبار الضباط في اسرائيل بسلاح الجو
الاسرائيلي في الاحتياط وما الى ذلك عمليا
خرجوا جميعا
لمحاوله ايجاد نوع من التوازن الان ما
تراه عمليا هو محاوله حسم في احد موقعين
اما في الكنيست لصالح نتنياهو الحكومه
وانت ترى كيف الامور باتجاه الهروله واما
في الشارع وهذا ما يقلق
لطالما تغنت اسرائيل انه هنالك فصل نظام
فصل في السلطات لا تداخل بين هذه السلطات
في حال اقر وهذا مستب اقر هذا القانون كما
يريد نتنياهو هل يمكن بعد ذلك الحديث عن
فصل السلطات في اسرائيل ابدا عمليا هذه
سلسله قوانين حقيقه وليس هي رزمه اعطيتك
مثالين في قضيه السيطره على تعيين القضاه
لك ان تتخيل ان يحاكم في ثلاث قضايا فساد
فلنسلم جدلا بان نتنياهو حكم بالسجن سنه
عندما يذهب في التماس الى المحكمه العليا
سيكون القاضي الذي يجلس هناك من تعيين
حكومه هذا بالضبط ما اخرج الناس عمليا حتى
من ناخبين الكود واليمين في اسرائيل
وخطوره الامر تبعد تذهب الى ابعد من ذلك
بكثير بحسب خبراء في اسرائيل بمعنى هناك
الان خطر تواجهه اسرائيل حتى امنيا وحتى
دبلوماسيا تخيل ان الولايات المتحده في كل
حوار مع اسرائيل ايران يحل ثالثا او رابعا
الان تتحدث مع هذه الحكومه في ضروره عدم
المساس في القضاء لان امريكا لن الدفاع عن
اسرائيل في المحافل الدوليه والامر الاخر
بانها عليها ان تهدئ الوضع في الموضوع
الفلسطيني وثالثا يحل الموضوع الايراني
الذي ارادتك هل يمكن القول باختصار انه
اسرائيل امام ازمه وجوديه الان املا هذه
مبالغه اثنين بالنسبه الى الفلسطينيين ما
الذي يتغير خصوصا ما يسمى الغاء قانون
الانفصال عن الضفه نوضح للمشاهدين ما الذي
يعني ذلك طبعا انا ضد الاحكام المطلقه لا
استطيع في هذه المرحله ان اخمن ان كان هذا
وجوديا ولا ولكن هذا الدراماتيكيا غير
مسبوق منذ 65 سنه نعم في اسرائيل عمليا
بالنسبه
للفلسطينيين اليوم الذي مرر طبعا هناك
قراءات اخرى لكن الذي مرر هو العوده عن فك
الارتباط عن شمال الضفه الغربيه المحتله
هناك اربع مستوطنات جرى اخلاء عام 2005
الان اسرائيل تقول عدلنا عن ذلك طبعا غزه
لا يستطيعون العوده اليها لان هناك
وفصائل الضفه الغربيه يست طيعون العوده
الى شماله هذا يعني ان فكره الدوله
الدولتين انتهت على الارض وهذا يعني بان
اسرائيل تتقدم بثبات اتجاه دوله ثنائيه
القوميه لا تريدها اساسا زياده حلبي دائما
شكرا جزيلا لك على هذه المشاركه
اغلقت حركه طالبان المكتبه النسائيه
الوحيده في العاصمه الافغانيه كابول بعد
سته اشهر من افتتاحها بدورها رجحت مريم
دبير احدى مؤسسات المكتبه رجحت ان الفتيات
سيعملن سرا على افتتاح مكتبات سريه ردا
على اقصاء طالبان الممنهج لهن يذكر انه في
اغسطس الماضي افتتح عدد من الافغانيات
مكتبه المراه في كابول والتي كانت الملجا
الوحيد لهن في بلد منع الفتيات والنساء من
العمل والتعليم وحتى ارتياد المرافق
العامه والترفيهيه
نشاطنا مستمره وفيها ايضا
ترامب يشن هجوما عنيفا على منافسه
الجمهوري رانديسانتوس ويصفه بغير المخلص
اهلا بكم من جديد يكثف الرئيس الامريكي
السابق دونالد ترامب هجماته على حاكم
فلوريدا سانتوس واصفا اياه بانه غير مخلص
وقال ان حياته السياسيه كانت ستنتهي لو لم
يؤيد حملته للناجحه في نهايه المطاف لعام
وفي اقوى تصريحاته الهجوميه قالت رمد ان
دي سانتوس كان ميتا كالكلب مضيفا انه كان
سياسيا وفقا لترامب الذي ادلى بهذه
التصريحات امام مجموعه صغيره من الصحافيين
على متن طائرته بعد ظهر يوم الاثنين في
طريقه الى ولايه
اضراب عمال النظافه في باريس احتجاجا على
رفع سن التقاعد يضع اشهر عواصم العالم تحت
اكوام من النفايات اكثر من 5000 طن من
النفايات تراكمت في باريس وسط تحذيرات من
تفاقم الازمه
من كان يتخيل يوما ان ياتي الى باريس
لاستكشاف انواع العطور او حتى الاستمتاع
بسحر الابنيه والشوارع ليجد نفسه محاصرا
وسط اكوام من القمامه ورائحه كريهه اصحاب
المطاعم والعمال هؤلاء يقومون بازاله
القمامه من امام مطاعمهم لانها اثرت على
اعمالهم بشده بيروت ما كانت هيك يعني
باياماتها زباله كل المطاعم يعني ما بعرف
شو بدي اقول
الزباله والروائح اللي بتطلع كيف العالم
بدها تيجي تاكل بس
والله كنا عايشين ببيروت احسن
وهيدي الزباله شلناها
اصحاب المطاعم قرروا التحرك بمفردهم على
امل ان تقوم البلديه بازاله اكوام القمامه
هذه العمليه ستتواصل طوال فتره ما بعد
الظهر سنقوم برش ماء الجافيل والتنظيف
بانتظار ان تاتي بلديه باريس وتاخذ كل هذه
القمامه اتمنى ان ينتهي هذا الاضطراب لكن
هذه المبادره لم ترق لبعض السكان الذين
اعتبروا انها لا تحل المشكله بل تقذفها
امام بيوت اناس اخرين لا ذنبلهم بما يحصل
هذا ليس امرا مقبولا ان تقوم المطاعم بنقل
نفاياتها امام ابنيه السكان انا ايضا لدي
قمامه لكن لن اقوم بالقائها امام مباني
الاخرين لاتخلص منها
الاضراب الذي دخل يومه السابع خلف حتى
الان اكثر من خمسه الاف طن من القمامه في
باريس وجعل هذه الاقوام غذاء للقوارض
والحشرات هذا المشهد لن ينتهي قريبا مع
استمرار عمال النظافه باضرابهم ما دفع
نائب رئيس كتله الاكثريا النيابيه في
البرلمان الى التحذير من انه في غضون ايام
قليله ستكون مدينه النور باريس مغطاه
بالكامل بالنفايات فادي الدهوك العربيه
باريس
وفادي يبقى معي من باريس للحديث عن هذا
الموضوع فادي اهلا وسهلا بك هل من حل او
حلول مطروحه لحل ازمه النفايات المتراكمه
في العاصمه الفرنسيه ام لا الامور ذاهبه
الى مزيد من التصعيد والتازم
اهلا طالب الامور ذاهبه الى مزيد من
التصعيد لان العمال صوتوا اليوم على تمديد
اضرابهم حتى يوم الاثنين المقبل كان من
المفترض ان ينتهي هذا الاضراب يوم غد
الاربعاء لكنهم صوتوا اليوم على تمديده
حتى يوم الاثنين المقبل حقيقه هذا الاضراب
هو اكبر حركه او اهم حركه اضراب لجامعي
القمامه في العشرين سنه الماضيه في باريس
اهميتها تاتي من انها من السياق الحالي في
فرنسا مع مساعد الحكومه رفع سن التقاعد
الى 64 عاما وايضا لانه يشمل مدن عديده
ليس باريس وحدها وانما نوت ورين ومدن
كثيره اخرى كذلك الوضع الاسوء كما ترون هو
في باريس العاصمه تعيش تحت ما يقرب من
6000 طن اليوم بحسب اخر التحديثات التي
اصدرتها بلديه باريس وايضا كان هناك فيديو
مسرب بدا ينشر يوم امس على وسائل التواصل
الاجتماعي
لاكوان من القمامه على مدخل قصر الرئاسه
الفرنسيه في
طبعا هذا الاضراب كما ذكرت سوف يتواصل الى
يوم الاثنين المقبل وبعض البلديات في
محاوله لايجاد حلول بدا اتجه الى القوه
لرفع القمامه من خلال ان تقوم باجبار
الموظفين المضربين على ان ياتوا للعمل
ويرفع هذه الاكوان من القمامه استنادا الى
بعض المواد القانونيه التي تصدر عن
المحاكم ويتم ابلاغهم بها من خلال مراكز
الشرطه نحن الان نسير في احد الشوارع في
الدائره الثامنه في باريس وهي احدى ارقى
المناطق في العاصمه باريس طبعا ايضا يوم
غد سيكون هناك تحرك احتجاجي جديد اليوم
قياده شرطه باريس اصدرت امرا لبلديه
العاصمه بالتحرك من اجل ازاله هذه
الاكوان من مسار التظاهره المرتقبه غدا
حتى لا يستفيد منها المتظاهرون لاشعالها
وافتعال الحوادث مع عناصر الشرطه طب فادي
خيارات الحكومه خيارات
حكومه رئيس ماكرون في حال استمرت النقابات
بالاضراب يعني الباط طرح انه ان تستعين
الحكومه بشركات خاصه لرفع النفايات ما هي
خيارات الحكومه يعني هل من حديث من هذا
القبيل في هذه المرحله
صحيح طالب هناك بعض البلديات تستفيد من
وجود شركات خاصه لجمع القمامه لكن الصعوبه
اليوم هي انه حتى عمال المحارق ومعامل
الفرز والتدوير يشتركون في هذه الحركه
الاحتجاجيه لذلك هناك معامل ضخمه جدا
تابعه لشركه سكتو على سبيل المثال في
افريسورسين وسانتوان وايضا في هذه المناطق
كلها مغلقه الان بسبب حركه الاضراب وحتى
الشركات الخاصه لا تتمكن من ان
تقوم بوضع هذه الاكوان من القمامه في تلك
المعامل السيناري الوحيد حتى الان هو ان
تقوم البلديات باستدعاء افراد الامن
المدني لازاله هذه الاكوان وهذا الامر حصل
في عام 2003 على سبيل المثال في مدينه
شمال فرنسا
ايضا حصل في مدينه مارسيليا جنوب البلاد
كان هناك اكثر من عشره الاف طن من القمامه
تمكنوا من رفعها من خلال هذا الامر طيب من
باريس مراسل العربيه فادي دهوك شكرا جزيلا
لك فادي على كل هذه المتابعه
اخيرا في نشره الخامسه اشتبكت الشرطه
الباكستانيه مع انصار رئيس الوزراء السابق
عمران خان خارج منزله في مدينه لاهور بشرق
البلاد حيث استخدمت الشرطه الغاز المسيل
للدموع وخراطيم المياه لتفريقهم وجاء ذلك
بعد ان حاولت الشرطه اعتقال عمران خان في
قضيه بيع هدايا من زعماء اجانب
[تصفيق]
نشره الخامسه انتهت اطيب التحيات والسلام
عليكم ورحمه الله وبركاته
[موسيقى]